wo ist dein leben
hallo ihr lieben kommt rein
hallo danke schön wo sind deine sachen
ist das alles ja ach nee danke noch mal
dass nico ein paar tage bei ihnen kann
ja ja das ist doch kein problem
möchten sie etwas trinken ich muss
leider sofort wieder gehen ich habe
heute noch in urlaub
ich komme bald wieder okay danke für
alles das wiedersehen so und du was
möchtest du denn trinken möchtest du
apfelsaft oder lieber eine
apfelsaftschorle sollen was ist das das
ist saft mit mineralwasser dann nehme
ich eine scholle bitte möchtest du auch
etwas essen jetzt ja was machst du denn
was gibt es denn es gibt fleisch fisch
und gemüse max dukaten karotten ich esse
gerne krawatten und du bist ja auch gern
karotten aber zuwarten du isst lieber zu
machen
ja ich esse lieber tomaten und kohlrabi
ist ducati am liebsten
nein ich finde kohlrabi nicht so lecker